all right everybody this hour is almost
up but I want to share one last gym on
social media that you may have missed
this is what I'm
[Music]
liking I know a lot of grown-ups who
award themselves with the caramel mon
the a or Java Chip prap from time to
time but it's not just grownups obsessed
with such fancy and fun drinks kids are
all about it as well and that's why a
Pittsburgh teacher used her third
graders love of one coffee chain as a
reward in the classroom no she did not
just completely dope them up and pump
them up full of caffeine uh she put on a
Starbucks incentive day transforming the
classroom into a coffee house while
slightly dropping lessons into the
recipe we have her on the line right now
everybody say hello to Taylor watching
on WTAE channel 4 what's up
Taylor hi Kelly how are you first of all
thank you so much for being a teacher we
love you for that for having me thank
you incredible incredible vocation so
explain the incentive day sure so almost
every month I have some sort sort of
positive behavior incentive for my third
graders um I've done things like a beach
day a camping day now my class this year
because they're huge fans they actually
asked me for the Starbucks day and I
said once they had 15 days of great
Behavior we would have this now I think
just in in about 15 days they earned it
um so of course I had to go all out I
decorated our entire classroom with the
green tablecloths I had actual coffee
cups and treat bags for them I myself
wore a green apron I played coffee house
jack music throughout the day and of
course had to sprinkle in a few
educational components so some examples
we corrected the spelling and
grammatical errors and a fictional menu
and we did some math by making change
with fictional orders um however their
favorite part as well as my favorite
part were our coffee breaks throughout
the day now I didn't have actual coffee
served to them I did have chocolate milk
but just like got the actual Starbucks
they came up I wrote their name on their
cup I took their order with the whipped
creams and syrups and called their names
and it was just a blast very cool man
thank you so much for being such an
incredible teacher and also for joining
us
today I I'm liking your post right now
Taylor all right thank and that's not
all our season long partner pilot pin
makers of friction the go-to race pin of
the Kelly Clarkson show want to
celebrate incredible teachers just like
you so they're giving the Hempfield area
school district $1,000 how's that sound
oh my God thank you so much thank you so
much ter have such a blessed day thank
you to all our guests this hour Jenna
Boer Barbara B KY spy Tiffany and Daniel
Carter all a great it's not TR
[Music]
[Applause]
to thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home